an outpouring of solidarity in the wake
of the attacks in Paris but is there a
political solution to stop the war the
so-called Islamic state spilling further
onto the streets of Europe is time to
find out welcome to the agenda six
coordinate attacks across Paris
massacred innocent people and left
hundreds injured in its aftermath the
country remains in a state of emergency
as police across France and Belgium hunt
the terrorist network behind the attacks
French president Francois Hollande has
declared war on Isis airstrikes already
underway with renewed force on Isis
strongholds in Syria but while other
member states answer the Republic's
battle cry at the strasburg plenary on
Wednesday morning expect a key debate on
terrorism and in the afternoon mep to
vote on measures to stop the
radicalization and recruitment of EU
citizens for the attacks in Paris have
now fueled the EU migration debate
should borders be controlled which would
then stop the free flow of migrants with
no solution on how to tackle the civil
war in Syria EU and African leaders met
last week in Valletta in Malta to find a
way to stabilize the refugee crisis what
comes next for the action plan follow
the debate on the outcome of the summit
on Wednesday a report that finally gets
the plenary mep will vote in the special
committee on taxes recommendations for
better tax practices special committee
caught a break when on tuesday 11
multinational companies including Google
and Facebook accepted an invitation to
discuss their tax practices with mep s
her vote takes place on Wednesday one in
three women have experienced physical or
sexual violence is time to orange your
world and show your support the color
orange has been chosen to symbolize a
brighter future one free of violence the
Parliament in Strasbourg will also be
lit up in orange to support the cause on
Wednesday evening from 8 p.m. to
midnight MEP s will debate the issue on
Wednesday morning and some are expected
to also dress up in orange and finally
the winner of the lux prize 2015 will be
unveiled in Strasbourg on Tuesday so
that gives you just a few more days
before either Mustang the lesson or
mediterranea take the crown and as
we have this gender take care and enjoy
the week